merci isabelle je crois que vous avez
exprimées tout à l'heure l'exigence
d'affirmer de revendiquer des valeurs ce
que nous sommes et pour moi ces valeurs
elles sont très clairement ancré à
droite
moi je suis fier d'être de droite et je
suis fier de défendre des valeurs de
droite et au premier rang de ces valeurs
de droite figurent la restauration de
l'autorité républicaine notre pays a
besoin d'autorité les français réclament
exige de l'autorité il le réclame et
exige de l'autorité d'autant plus qu'ils
mesurent ce que les socialistes au
quotidien conduisent en sapant les
principes même les bases de cette
autorité regardant l'autoroute 1 bloquer
une journée entière par une communauté
qui revendiquait d'inverser décision de
justice de faire libérer un terrain
qu'en regardant moyrand regardons ce qui
se passe sur un territoire de la
république où tu es où installer jeunes
non terrible qui signifie que sur
plusieurs kilomètres carrés de la
république
des milliers de personnes ne sont plus
soumis aux lois de la république
alors oui nous avons l'exigence de
réclère de restaurer cette autorité
républicaine
je crois que ce principe devra être
placée au premier rang de notre projet
l'autorité républicaine c'est aussi la
garantie que chaque citoyen soit protégé
face aux menaces et notamment face aux
menaces terroristes
l'autorité républicaine c'est faire en
sorte que notre nation choisissent ceux
qui veulent venir sur leur territoire
l'autorité républicaine c'est dire que
aucune loi religieuse ne peut être
supérieure aux lois de la république
ce principe d'autorité doit être remis
au premier rang de nos valeurs et vous
avez raison de souligner la nécessité
que nous soyons très exigeant que nous
soyons très combatif que nous soyons
très volontaire
et pour moi je le dis clairement nous
n'avons pas à aller vers une politique
de consensus mou nous devons réaffirmer
ce que nous sommes et pour moi je le dis
avec fierté et ce n'est pas une honte je
suis de droite et j'ai la fierté de le
revendiquer